thanks to insta360 for agreeing to
sponsor this experiment
video games have this thing called god
mode right you're probably familiar with
it games like minecraft or gary's mod
even like halos forge mode they allow
you to move anywhere and see anything
without the bounds of physics holding
you to the ground you'd even frame up
shots that you'd never be able to frame
up in real life but what if you could do
it in real life
[Music]
now drones come pretty close because
they can fly and go anywhere and 360
cameras also come close because they can
see everything now if you combine them
together you'll actually get the video
we made last year where i put a 360
camera on a drone and that got some
pretty cool results but it also ended up
proving to be really limited because you
could see the drone in the shot in god
mode you can't see your feet you know
you don't see the cameraman on avengers
every time you see the drone it ruins
the shot even if it is kind of cool in
its own regard and that is a problem
with all 360 cameras because they do see
everything if you put it on top of a
drone you're always going to see the
drone so i have to figure out a way to
somehow frame out the drone in a way
that i can get any camera angle i want
at any time you know a true god mode
camera and i think i might be able to
finally pull that off with this camera
right here from insta360 but the
challenge now is can i do that without
breaking this thing in the process let
me explain
this is the same exact camera we put on
the drone last year and this is a great
camera i like it a lot but the thing
about the new one here
is that it is modular this thing comes
apart and i could put different lenses
on it such as this action cam lens and
sensor and then literally put that all
back together see i just made a gopro in
the time it took me to explain it to you
they even have a leica lens with a 5k
sensor but the component that makes this
project possible is the split lens
what's crazy about this lens is that
it's actually two separate lenses being
able to separate these lenses allows you
to put things between them so the actual
specific product that allows this whole
project to exist is the insta 360 1r
aerial edition they specifically made a
version of this camera that can attach
to the dji mavic and i was like
this is it like this is what we've been
wanting this makes the drone invisible
this is a blind disc that can't be seen
by the camera so the propeller blades
the drone itself can't be seen in the
final image so the idea that i'm trying
to do is basically adapt the exact same
concept from the aerial edition to work
with my specific drone
there's a reason why i don't fly around
people is because if i did make a
mistake and hit a person they can be
seriously injured
so i don't fly around people that close
unless you're jam so that's where i got
a very special drone for this it's this
drone right here this is called the shin
drones squirt it's a little squirt this
is actually printed out of tp material
so this is technically flexible here
that means it's very durable
so i got this drone from rotor right
they're pretty much the best one-stop
shop for all things fpv related so this
i can actually fly inside should i like
fly it right now should i like just fire
it up i think jake will get angry oh
they're playing smash over there i think
i can make them lose smash okay i gotta
do this i gotta do this hold up
[Music]
why would you do that
[Music]
[Music]
and take off
i should really watch where i'm flying
if only there's a way to see everywhere
that i'm flying
my god that's so much fun to fly so now
i got to get the 360 camera on there so
let's talk about how i'm going to go
about actually doing that the 1r aerial
edition comes with all the components i
need for this project including the
camera but the mavic mount won't work
with my drone so i have to design a new
mount that will this gives me an
opportunity to actually explore
different lens placements too i don't
have to put them top and bottom like on
the mavic is there a better way look at
the single point of contact on the
bottom you don't want to have a nice
delicate piece of glass be like the
first thing the drone hits so why not
put some legs that will support it so
that it won't actually ever touch the
lens anything above this plane here will
be visible so legs are out of the
question putting it on the side here
could work however the distance between
these two lenses is now pretty
substantial so it kind of makes more
sense to put the lens facing forward
here so i need to 3d print some sort of
mount that will hold these two lenses in
place while not blocking my fpv camera
while also holding the brain of the
insta360 the battery of the insta360 and
the battery of the drone
it printed beautifully and just like
that i've made the world's jankiest 360
camera so as i move this around i
anticipate it'll just look like i don't
have an arm i might not even be in the
shot altogether that'd be awesome no
matter where you place these lenses
you're going to have a stitch disc right
because it's two lenses put them
together there's going to be a circle
where the two images are stitched
together at what point does nick fall a
way that disc can kind of be considered
like the bermuda triangle of 360 cameras
the further away these lenses get the
bigger that bermuda triangle gets and
the more things disappear within it i'm
now putting it at a different distance
than any of the insta360 engineers
intended i'm inherently introducing
problems that aren't calibrated for
example i cannot use the included lens
guards because it ruins my stitch in
this mod that means i might be running
into some stitching issues and i kind of
want to mitigate that
that's a pretty rough stitch line i have
a dilemma here nick i can't do front and
back the stitch line is too obvious my
only option is to put it top bottom
after all that well at least now i know
you know beat saber
[Music]
i'm gonna go ahead and just commit to
this vertical design here of basically
just putting the lenses on top and
bottom of the drone i'm gonna do that by
designing a mount that utilizes the
existing screw holes and screws of the
drone itself it'll sit between the rear
propellers while still sitting above and
below the entire drone basically
incorporating the camera into the drone
itself then i'll go ahead and 3d print
that using lots of support structures so
that it can print the direction i want
it to print i feel it is more important
to get a better shot at the risk of my
equipment than having safer equipment
but a useless shot
okay so
this is the thing i printed
print supports i'm breaking it
you cannot print on nothing you always
have to have something underneath for
the plastic lay on top of
[Music]
that just seems like you're destroying
it
it worked it printed beautifully so see
the little holes that's where the screws
are gonna go oh yeah
and just like that you got the lens down
here and you got the lens up there
there's a little bit of a gap and i can
easily fix that by just putting like
some uh electrical tape in my thumb
stuck out
okay where'd the electrical tape go
i literally had electrical here a moment
ago
[Music]
dude it was literally right here
literally right here
what's this
oh it's literally right there
this is why my wife is so annoyed at me
story my life they also sent me these
little ribbon cables to actually attach
to the lens and then attach to the brain
now there are actually a couple ribbon
cables inside of the mavic mount you
just gotta like take out some screws and
they're right there and the thing about
ribbon cables though is that they're
very delicate so i'm a little concerned
about breaking them because these are my
only set just try to feed it in but it
keeps wanting to like not feed
oh
dude
no
ren
oh wait no i think this is okay yep okay
good
i fixed it
it's a flying drone jan it looks like
you're flying failure i'm not afraid for
my life he's just bitter
dude i'm so motivated right now i gotta
get this to work you know what i think
this is ready to fly
[Applause]
[Music]
how's it feel to fly it's it's a chungus
[Music]
[Music]
this this actually is pretty sweet i
mean there's some stitch problems but
regardless of that this is so cool i can
get any camera angle i want
[Music]
oh by the way this app actually is
pretty freaking sweet i highly recommend
using your app over the computer for a
lot of this stuff obviously for being
able to reframe your shots very
organically like it's a real camera if
you go to the stories feature down here
at the bottom of the app there's all
these cool features like stop motion
stuff it automatically recognizes where
you're walking and we'll repeat those
same positional frames to give you like
the stop motion effect which is pretty
cool there's also other things like auto
time shift or like bullet time mixing
another really cool one is this time
flip thing where it makes you look like
you're flying through walls and it does
all of this stuff automatically just
from your uh oh dude the clone trail
seriously dude automatic clone effects
look at that look at that it
automatically does it that's actually
freaking sweet it gives you professional
grade like effects editing without doing
anything i only wanted to make this for
the cine loop so i could fly like close
quarters but i also want to fly fast and
to do that i gotta attach this to my
actual racing drone so i'll probably end
up just adapting the same exact design
to work with my racing drum so if i
crash and scratch anything that's bad
hey do you want this camera without
paying any money well you're in luck
maybe because insta360 is actually doing
a give you give you me give me a
giveaway
on their channel you gotta go subscribe
follow the instructions in our
description down below but really i
think you should subscribe to their
youtube channel they got some pretty
cool videos they're at the forefront of
consumer 360 technology man like so oh
my god are you gonna pick up his audio
did you know you can get fake drone
shots yeah you just put it on a really
long stick and it looks so far away that
it looks like it's flying yeah there's
tons more videos like that on their
youtube channel i definitely recommend
checking it out all right back to the
[Music]
camera is video
i mean anytime i get to fly it's a good
time
okay i gotta be careful not to fly too
recklessly because i don't want to
actually crash this it's just a test to
see if the footage even works
[Applause]
i'm killing clinton nick right now
you're on the street you're coming back
[Music]
all right i'm gonna come in for a
landing ready
that was a fun flight so we went camping
in the desert a year ago and we
discovered this ridge that we could one
wheel along that was one of the best
trails i'd ever ridden 360 degree
panoramic views ever since that time
i've been dreaming of going back and
flying my drone along that ridge oh man
i've literally thought about that so
many times over the last year and i
finally have my chance to do it this
weekend but until then i'm gonna spend
the rest of this week getting as many
sweet shots as possible
okay so a few things have happened since
the test flight upstairs and i have got
some things to fill you in on first off
this works really well it flies really
well and i'm getting some great footage
being able to fly through the trees over
the rocks and have the camera literally
look up at the bridge look down at the
rocks it was all looking really cool i
landed i put on a new battery i set it
up ready to take off
and then this happened
[ __ ] seriously
if you've ever used a camera i'm sure
that probably hurt you in your soul just
seeing a lens scraped across gravel and
sure enough i scratched the lenses both
of them but that's why i have an extra
set of lenses in case that happens
so the next day i went back out with a
fresh set of lenses i went to the sears
building i was like okay this time i
have a plan of attack i'm not gonna try
anything crazy i'm just gonna do some
circles around the top of the sears
building
[Music]
so i had a plan of attack for how to
land this guy i had my rear car door
open and i was gonna just fly into my
car and land on my nice cushy seats
and this is where things get worse yes i
scratched both lenses and i scratched
them worse than the first set of lenses
i now have zero non-scratched lenses for
this project and we have this epic
camping trip planned for this video this
weekend and we can't get another set of
lenses between now and then but you know
what that means right embrace the jank
we are still gonna go out into the
desert we're still gonna ride one wheels
we're still gonna fly drones with a 360
mod on it and i'm still gonna get some
epic footage i'm excited for this
weekend in spite of all these setbacks
so the plan is that we wait till around
golden hour we head up to the top of the
ridge
the plan is to film in intervals i race
out along ahead of the guys set up my
drone get it up in the air as they come
by and pass me and continue along to the
next ridge where they will then stop and
allow me to pass them again and then we
just kind of do that over and over again
[Music]
wow
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
uh
[Music]
in spite of all the setbacks that was an
amazing trip i got some really
incredible footage that i'm actually
still really proud of and in fact we're
planning a whole corridor short film
using this camera platform because i
think the ideas are literally endless
with this i mean it's god
mode camera
great news though i have new lenses
coming in the mail so i'm going to
continue getting some epic footage i'm
also making all of the 3d files
available on my thingiverse account so
you can download for free if you want to
print them yourself or if you have the
camera you don't have a printer there's
actually a frame called the cinebird
from stan fpv which i also recommend i
want you guys to do me a favor if you
thought any of the footage that i got
for this video was pretty sweet share it
with your friends it'd mean a lot to me
i don't care if you subscribe or not
nico might i just want you to share this
video